hi there uh carrying on from the
uh joe saburi the twenty josh brewery
we've done the first ten
and uh will now do the kata movements
i apologize once to cite a sense he's
saying so sorry i didn't speak japanese
so i would talk to him he looked at me
and
threw a translator said why would you
want to speak japanese you're english
aren't you
so this made me realize that
it's nice to know the japanese names and
it's a very good thing to learn them
but it's not the end of the world you
know if you don't
so uh
as i say it's all part of the package
i learned as much japanese as i could i
studied the language
but uh forgotten it all now and
sometimes uh counting in japanese is
also good
but you know as i say it's the result
we're trying to get to that's important
the result is you finding our senses
aikido
and the path that he wanted us to find
and we do this through
weapons and taijitsu and the weapons are
to
improve the taijitsu they're not a
separate item
where you'd need a weapon to be able to
perform it
okay so
this as long as you
haven't got it too loose just hands
comfortable around the joe
when it's down here in the groin this is
in a sort of a nothing position
you could say a relaxed human being
position a martial arts position
might be just holding it here ready
it's not quite ready because it hasn't
gone far enough back
but when i take it back i'm not just
going to take it back like this
this is a an action of their hand
i need to have an action go through from
head to toe
through the body so
so this is nothing
this can be in a relaxed position and
now when i'm going to combine
the the ready position
so i pull it back a little bit
i step back a little bit and i sink my
body
your focus sharpens
but you don't stare you focus
sharpen your focus by looking in all
directions
so i'm looking in all directions
so from the ready position we're going
to go
to the catatec kotati movements
slightly offline
if i do if i went the other side this
side
it would turn my body now in the wrong
way
so when i come around
it wouldn't be going forward stepping
forward
at this point don't feel that you've
stopped
or you're leaning back
be in a middle position in a ready
position
the feeling should be like you're
loading a bone
you're loading the app the bow to let
the arrow go
okay
go to the end of the joe
with this hand
this comes up from the head
from the head the elbow doesn't want to
be high
this is a common mistake don't let this
elbow come back
the joe must be higher than the
joe must be higher than the elbow
once you get here this end
is in line with your own temple
the upper hand is going up to heaven
so you feel that you've got some
stretching stretching stretching
okay so that's the thing you don't do
this this is the feeling
so you feel like you're grounded here
here's the earth
and here's the heaven
putting these feelings in will energize
you
and develop your coaching develop your
key the spirit and the power together
nothing ready come on
middle position
temple grounded earth
heaven is on
it's so that you can come down to strike
it's just a one a one strike this
if you do this
but it's okay it gives you a little bit
of
freedom a little bit of flow a little
bit of excitement
that's okay to do these things after all
it has to be enjoyable
but i could also be enjoyable
hey
i'm already in the ready position you
see i've come back to the ready position
don't come back to just a relaxed
position
i'll show it incorrectly even though you
should never show anything really
incorrectly
okay this is incorrect don't do this
please
always keep your marshall awareness
this is an uppercut to the chin
if you reverse it from here
obviously you're striking with the side
of the head
so as long as you're accurate you can
add this but the
movement the technique is this
thank you
under the chin
heaven
okay coming from the other forms
please remember don't look down it's
very unmarshalled
so many teachers out there iwama as well
they're looking down at the end of it or
they're looking down when they start
at the floor to where they see where the
joe is totally wrong
you won't see cytosensei doing it if he
looks down it's because he's thinking
like that
he doesn't look down and see where his
jaw is you don't know where your joe is
you haven't trained enough
okay
don't worry all this stuff